pro-wrestler slash actor slash smack
treet john cena yes I said snag you
treat I did
why on one knows him as the tough guy in
the red pants but he's really a big old
softie you know John showed both sides
when he got down on the mat on bended
knee I've been waiting so long to ask
you this Stephanie Nicole Garcia colas
would you marry me in the ring and
putting a ring on it
Cena picked WrestleMania 33 is the spot
to propose to girlfriend of nearly five
years Nikki Bella
Danny
my god
I mean what's not to love about that
massive Tiffany sparkler the proposal
comes as Nikki continues her WWE come
back after neck surgery and John
prepares to take time off to make more
movies your career is just literally
kind of going in this direction be right
out I mean do you pinch yourself
I really am fortunate that I get a lot
of opportunities I have a very good
perspective of the pendulum swings both
ways man as you're going there now it
may swing who knows
I look like Mark Wahlberg ate Mark
Wahlberg Cena will follow his
scene-stealing roles and trainwreck
sisters and daddy's home Scott likes
form arms by voicing Ferdinand the bull
in the upcoming animated film based on
the classic children's book I'm not a
fighting bull you don't need to be a
fighting bull you just have to look like
a fighting man I kind of make a living
with WWE so everyone sees me in the ring
but there there is a lot more to me than
that so it's it's a story that hits
really close to home and although
Hollywood demands are keeping John away
from home he and new fiance Nikki have
more to celebrate yeah the milestone
birthday coming up that's a big one for
me I'm gonna turn 40 yeah so uh I'm
still going like I'm 20 but I'm 40 so I
look around and like where did the time
go
I'll be in Atlanta filming a movie
called the pact hopefully see my lady on
that day I really would like to see her
so hopefully she'll come on in and say
hello but we'll see surprise him that'd
be a good idea and John's birthday is on
the 23rd of this month so Nikki you got
about three weeks to make this happen
all right and for the record nikki has
made it clear to everybody that their
wedding will not take place in a
wrestling ring
[Music]